[Music]
we're showing gratitude to good deed
doers all season long like this very
deserving through gooder take a look
my name is canard johnson i'm a high
school girls basketball and softball
coach in chicago illinois when i was a
teenager i was shot
that's how i lost my arm
i was down i didn't want to do anything
and
one of my friends asked me to come be
coach at his school when i came on board
i saw the girls met with them some girls
had no socks on
some girls had shoes with holes in them
so when i get paid i would buy them
shoes socks anything they needed the
girls always used to come in the gym
i can't do this i can't do that
and i had to motivate them
i have one arm if i can do it with one
arm you can do it with two we went 14
and on our first year
right now i cannot be with the kids
because of the epidemic but i have kids
that need food
so
i
sent an uber over
with food for them
my first job is working at the school
and my second job
is taking care of these kids
my name is kayla herron coach johnson
just always been supportive of the girls
because i remember at times where i
didn't have shoes to practice in or play
in the game and he literally took the
team to go buy shoes and stuff like that
he still follows me to this day even
though i'm a college student he calls
and checks up on me i would like to
personally thank you coach for
everything that you've done for me
supporting me through all my highs and
my lows believing in me when i didn't
believe in myself just thank you for all
your hard work and your dedication to us
and i love you
[Music]
this package just came
and it's from the drew barrymore show
for me she didn't have to do this
[Music]
thank you carl for making a difference
fancy flowers
a lovely sweatshirt this is nice
i love it
i have a gift card for my girls
they're gonna love shopping at walmart
thank you dr
i really appreciate this
thank you my name is casey and this is
my mom penny and we're icu nurses at
vista medical center east in waukegan
illinois it's been an honor and a
privilege to be a nurse for 35 years
because i was able to take care of our
patients emotionally physically
spiritually and mentally
i wouldn't trade being a nurse for
anything seeing my mom give care to
people has been so rewarding and i wish
to do the same for all my patients and
their families
my second day was when the pandemic was
announced
and it really solidified why i wanted to
be a nurse
being able to work alongside my daughter
means so much to me and i could really
show her
how
to take care of the people or a patient
who are very critically ill
and i'm so proud that she takes that
opportunity to
work alongside me
working with my mom throughout the
pandemic in the icu has been an honor
and i've been able to learn so much from
her
hi
i'm the daughter of penny and sister of
casey mom you've been working in the icu
for
over 30 years and that's so incredible
and casey you were thrown right into it
last year when you finished nursing
school
neither of you refused to take care of
anyone who is positive and you risk your
health to take care of other patients i
love you guys thank you for being true
heroes during this pandemic
[Music]
drew just sent them some packages let's
see what they got
drew sent us something
one two
what three this very nice
oh thanks drew thank you so much
oh my gosh those are pretty good yeah
[Music]
my name is miley cronin i am 15 years
old i am a sophomore in high school from
northern virginia
pretty early on i guess i realized that
the coven 19 pandemic was going to be a
nightmare what with school closures
restrictions shortages people getting
sick since i couldn't leave the house i
turned to gofundme
the donations to my page are the funds i
use to buy meals for the local
businesses i partner with and they are
then delivered to hospital personnel
grocery store workers or police officers
additionally the proceeds provide funds
for local businesses so it's really just
a two-stop effort
over 900 meals have been delivered
the hope is just to raise more money and
provide even more meals and gift cards
throughout the next few months it's
launched into a way that i never could
have imagined and for people who think
that they don't have the time or that
they can't contribute and that their
voices won't be heard they absolutely
will it's exactly what the world needs
right now
[Music]
hey everybody it's mac miley's brother
and we just received an awesome present
from the drew barrymore show
why are you filming me
what
no
oh my gosh
thanks for making a difference
[Music]
oh this is so exciting
oh these are beautiful it just keeps
getting better look at this
oh look at this drew gutter no
i don't know what to say this is this is
incredible i'm so grateful and excited
to be a drew gooder this is the greatest
honor ever i love your show i love you
and
thank you so much this is incredible
thank you thank you thank you
hello my name is belinda mason i founded
the organization women on wheels here in
dallas texas we're a non-profit
organization we work strictly offer
donations we have tried to help
absolutely everybody we did a cancer
walk we did a cancer run
also we took over six nursing homes we
gave them toiletries we even took over
two parking lots with two semi trucks
full of food during the pandemic for the
people who were in need
during christmas time we adopted kids
and we gave them coats shoes pants
shirts and toys putting smiles on
people's faces is breathtaking
it is overwhelming when you can put one
smile on a person's face you feel like
the joy never ends
hello i'm sinclair i'm belinda's friend
and i just received the package from the
drew barrymore show
write down that
sitting at the door
man she's gonna be excited for this
hey baby hey
what you doing what are you doing
nothing filming you
what you got something special today
baby i don't know what it is
who is that from
shrimp
i love it
thanks for making a difference through
oh i love flowers oh jesus what is this
oh this is gonna help so much
oh
we love you thank you from the women's
on wheel here in dallas texas drew
barrymore
my name is shonda lemon
i've been a postal carrier for eight
years now i've been delivering on this
route in particular for four years
that's how i met helen after she took a
fall last year i began wrapping rubber
bands around her mail so that she can
grip it more easily
i noticed that she hadn't picked up her
mail for three days which is unusual i
called 9-1-1 and they found her on the
floor she had been laying there for
three days
and they were able to save her life it's
overwhelming and i'm just happy that
i it wasn't any worse situation she's
alive and well and soon enough i'll be
able to speak to her myself and
talk to her like i normally do
jonda you are our angel
we just
can't thank you enough you mean
everything to us god bless shonda for
having discovered me and realized that
there was something wrong that i was not
picking up the mail not many people
would care that much but she certainly
did and i have to thank her with all my
heart for the life that i am still
living
[Music]
hey i'm shamari my mom just received a
surprise gift from drew barrymore and
she's on her way home and she's going to
see the surprise box sitting outside i
can't wait to see this
oh this is so cute
oh
thank you
thank you
okay
this is a very kind gesture
thank you so much drew and i wish you
all of the great blessings upon you for
even thinking of me thank you so much
i'd say they were more than a true
gooder that was a drew greater
[Music]
you